bonjour christophe chira merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin tôt
sur rtl france vous avez décidé de ne
pas ouvrir votre établissement ce matin
pour montrer votre mécontentement face à
l'extension de ce pass sanitaires dans
les cafés et les restaurants
oui c'est ça c'est pour montrer mon
mécontentement et puis pour aussi
préserver ce qui reste de notre
trésorerie puisque on sait de
l'expérience des lieux de culture depuis
le 21 juillet qui ont enregistré une new
era d'activité des fréquentations de 70
% ou plus au bout d'un moment il vaut
mieux rester fermer et ouvrir et engagé
des frais pour lesquelles il aurait pas
le chiffre d'affaires suffisamment pour
compenser voilà est ce que vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes suivi dans votre
démarche par vos confrères
on a eu énormément de restaurateurs qui
ont rejoint le collectif ces derniers
jours parce qu'ils sont effectivement
très inquiet j'ai bien compris ce qui
allait se passer
ma foi c'est un vrai signe que cette
mesure est au delà de son aspect
liberticide et sans vraiment beaucoup de
sens sanitaire puisque les informations
qui nous viennent des autres pays qu'ils
ont faits l'attestent
bien sûr que tous ces gens qu'on perd on
est en pleine saison d'été est en train
de nous fourguer notre saison voilà on
n'a rien fait depuis cette année on a
été fermé on a souscrit à toutes les
mesures pour nous a demandé d'appliquer
et on continue encore un finalement à
piétiner notre activité c'est le fruit
de ces avec ça convient nous c'est avec
ça qu'on vit est bien évidemment que
tout le monde est inquiet parce que tout
le monde est touché et on voit une
arrivée quasi massive de bars et de
restaurants au sein de notre collectif
qui sont complètement en panique
votre démarche donc à ne pas ouvrir
restés fermés c'est juste aujourd'hui ou
bien ce que vous allez l'appliquer dans
le temps sur la durée parce que si c'est
juste aujourd'hui en ouvrant après vous
irait à l'encontre de vos convictions et
si vous restez fermes et est-ce que vous
n'allez pas perdre du chiffre d'affaires
même si vous nous expliquer tout à
l'heure c'était peut-être mieux pour
votre trésorerie est ce que vous ne
prenez pas un risque pour votre
reprise en restant fermés alors c'est à
partir d'aujourd'hui me concernant et
tous ceux qui sont dans cet état de
fragilité on les invite vraiment à faire
leurs calculs
parce que je vous assure qu'il vaut
mieux rester fermés que de travailler la
20 ou 30%
donc c'est à partir d'aujourd'hui
jusqu'à ce qu'on voit comment on va
pouvoir contester ce pass sanitaire qui
ne s'applique pas partout curieusement
et on nous explique que ces sanitaires
donc on va a lancé un recours évidemment
devant le conseil d'état
on va engager d'autres actions et voir
comment on peut survivre ménager la
chèvre et le chou j'allais dire mais on
peut pas faire deux poids deux mesures
solution l'appliquent
de toute façon on va on va perdre du
chiffre et on va perdre de la marge
on va travailler à perte et si on
n'applique pas on va effectivement se
priver de chiffre d'affaires mais à la
fin on préserve ce qu'on a deux de
trésorerie finalement et ça durera le
temps que ça durera
et puis il restait moral il ya un moment
où on se prête à une discrimination qui
est inédite et moi je sur le plan de
l'éthique personnelle je me refuse de me
prêter à cette doctrine de clients que
je ne peux pas c'est pas possible
vous venez d'évoquer un rat un recours
devant le conseil d'état
qu'est ce que vous allez exactement
et vous évoquez d'autres recours quels
sont ils
c'est à l'étude je peux pas vous
répondre tout de suite nécessairement
une rupture d'égalité de toute façon
puisque vous avez vous-même indiqué
qu'ils étaient concernés qui ne
l'étaient pas la restauration collective
les ans les routiers etc
c'est tant mieux pour eux des gens c'est
très bien comme ça mais on voit bien que
du coup il ya deux poids deux mesures
encore une fois encore une fois elle
s'était 18 mois que c'est comme ça donc
ce sera au moins sur ce motif là on va
voir sur quels autres va pouvoir agir
nos avocats sont à l'heure et tout ça va
se faire très rapidement
et puis on va voir si comment on va
pouvoir mobiliser nos confrères
comment pouvoir manifester tout ça en
place publique comment on va informer
les gens de ski de ce qu'est notre vie
parce que vraiment c'est très compliqué
je sais pas ce qu'on a fait à nos
gouvernants mais ils nous en veulent
vraiment beaucoup
nos gouvernants justement l'exécutif
ainsi goût de nombreux professionnels de
santé estime que la vaccination anti
qu'ovide et l'application du pass
sanitaire est le seul moyen d'éviter un
nouveau confinement est donc une
fermeture des bars et restaurants et
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez à je
leur réponds que c'est trop facile de
dire ça ça fait 18 mois que l'on nous
explique que c'est la dernière que c'est
le dernier effort qu'il faut appliquer
telle ou telle mesure qu'il faut fermer
parce que après c'est le retour à la vie
normale se fait 18 mois que c'est comme
ça c'est facile de dire ça mais alors
quelle serait l'alternative d'après vous
pourra se passe sanitaires pour le
secteur de la restauration qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire alors écouté jusqu'à
lors on a appliqué les gestes barrières
on n'est pas des irresponsables du tout
hein
on a appliqué des gestes barrières on a
fait de la distanciation social on a mis
du gel à disposition tout le monde etc
et tout s'est bien passé je ne crois pas
que le moindre clusters et aient été
relevés dans un établissement de
restauration je ne crois pas et les
études dont on nous parle ne sont pas
des études sont des enquêtes ou des
sondages donc il faut rétablir un peu
les choses au bout d'un moment vraiment
et encore une fois je vous le demande si
c'est si c'était si dangereux que ça
pourquoi les restaurations collectives
pourquoi le restaurant de l'assemblée
nationale du sénat ne serait pas
concernée par exemple c'est curieux ça
voilà et pourquoi les relais routier ne
serait pas concernée qu'est ce qu'il est
en quoi sont-ils des lieux où le virus
n'interviendrait paria rien aucune aucun
clusters dans la restauration n'a été
remonté depuis 18 mois mais c'est
suffisant comme démonstration
merci christophe sira d'avoir répondu à
nos questions et bonne chance à vous
évidemment je rappelle que vous êtes
restaurateur et représentants du
collectif les pendus